Bir güzel bückcik TYT örneceğim cofa
okuluna YouTube'un en Jorf kanalına
hepiniz hoş geldiniz. 39 günde ayrıntılı
coğrafya kampımızın bugün geldik 3ün
günne. Bugün sizinle beraber atmosferi,
atmosferin katmanlarını ve atmosferin
etkilerini işleyeceğiz. Hocam şöyle bir
durduğun gibi. Hocam konu sıralamasında
bu yok ki diyorsun. Çok güzel bir
strateji izleyeceğiz sizinle. Şimdi
takvim kısmında göstereceğim sana nasıl
bir strateji izleyeceğimizi. Bu videoda
neler olacak? Bu videoda ilk önce
ayrıntılı bir şekilde atmosferi
öğreneceğiz. Sonra kodlama kısmından
kodlamayla özet yapacağız. En sona
rehberlik köşesindeki bugünkü konumuz ya
başarısız olursam korkusu. Bu korkuyu
işleyeceğiz rehberlik köşesinde. Bu üç
konuyla bu üç kısımla beraber videoyu
bitireceğiz. Çok uzun bir video
olmayacak merak etme. Hızlıca takvime
geçelim şimdi. Bir dakika ya ben böyle
geçmiyordum. Şöyle diyorduk. Yunus
hocayla bir defa öğren. Bir daha asla
unutma. Zedua ile eğitim her yerde.
Şimdi geldik bakın şurada nasıl
ilerliyoruz. Birinci günümüzü bitirdik.
İkinci günümüzü bitirdik. 3üncü günümüze
geliyoruz. Bakın 3üncü günümüzde
normalde atmosfer ve atmosferin etkileri
olmaması lazım. Normalde önünüzdeki
kitapta öyle değil. Nasıl? Önünüzdeki
kitapta şunlar var. Dünyanın şekli ve
hareketleri, coğrafi konum, harita
bilgisi. Şimdi geldik buraya. Ben
yıllardır bu işi yapıyorum. Özellikle
okuldayken hep bu konuları arkaya
atardım. Çünkü biliyorum burada ciddi
anlamda sıkıntı yaşıyorsun. YouTube'da o
düzen bozulmasın diye bunu pek yapmamaya
çalışıyordum ama artık canıma tak etti.
Çünkü sizler biliyorum ki bu konuları
gördüğünüzde pes ediyorsunuz. Coğrafya
çalışmayı bırakıyorsunuz. Neden ya
arkadaş? Doğa ve insandan başladım.
Coğrafyanın bölümleri ne kadar güzel
gitti. Kodlamalarla öğrendik. Asıl zaten
oradan soru geliyor. Gelirse
kodlamalarla öğrendik. Bir hevesim oldu
diyorsun. Ne güzel başladık. Tam
çalışacağız. testleri de yaptım falan.
Sonra coğrafyanın tarihi gelişimi geldi.
E orada da testleri yaptım dedin. Ne
kadar güzel gidiyor ya. Zaten haritaları
öğrendin geldin. Ya ne kadar güzel
gidiyor bu coğrafya. Ben bu coğrafyayı
hallederim. O hissi aldın kalk. Dünyanın
şekli hareketleri geldi. Dünyanın şekli
ve hareketlerini görünce ya bir çalıştın
olmadı. Testini çözüyorsun olmuyor.
Gıcık bir konu ve gereksiz de soru da
çıkmıyor. Hadi bakalım dünya şekli ve
hareketlerini geçiyorsun. Sonra coğrafi
konum geliyor. Orada da yine sorun aynı
şey. Yok işlem hesaplamaları bilmem ne.
harita bilgisine geliyorsun. Yine aynı
problem. Bu üç konu bakın hesapladım.
Girdim, eski kampıma baktım. 4 saatlik
konu yani 8 video 4 saat. Düşünebiliyor
musunuz? Siz bu 8 video 4 saati
atlayamazsınız. atlayamazsan kastım şu o
zorlu süreci geçip de asıl gerekli
konulara gelene kadar bütün motivasyon
her şey biter. O yüzden bu 8 videoluk
yani 4 saatlik ama hiç soru gelmeyen bu
lanetli konuları aldık en sona ki moral
motivasyonunuzu düşürmesin. Göreceksiniz
bu sene coğrafya kampının bu dizaynı
sizi zirveye taşıyacak. Coğrafyada
hevesiniz devam edecek. Bakın biz nereye
geldik şimdi? Atmosfer ve atmosferin
katmanlarından, etkilerinden
başlayacağız. Devam edeceğiz. Aradan
onları çektik. Şimdi bakın aradan onları
çektik. Ya şu gördüğünüz konu var ya
geçen sene MSÜ'de çıktı. Ondan önceki
sene TYT'de çıktı. Şu konuya gelene
kadar o 3 tane 8 videoluk 4 saatlik konu
sizi mahvediyordu. Bu konuya
ulaşamıyordunuz. Ulaşamayınca otomatik
olarak bir tane soru gidiyordu. Biz ne
yaptık şu an? Bakın iki tane konu
işledik. Zaten burada coğrafyanın
bölümlerinden geliyor bir sorumuz bizim.
Hadi şundan gelmiyor ikinci konudan. O
kısa bir konu. Anlaşılabilir bir konu
zaten. Tak. Geldik sorunun geleceği
3üncü kısma. Hiç moral motivasyonumuzu
düşürmedik. Zaten biz bu konuları
işlemeyeceğiz demiyoruz. Bu konuları
yine işleyeceğiz ama en sona işleyelim.
Zaten kampı yarıya kadar anca
götürebiliyorsunuz. Pes edip bırakmayın.
Hevesinizi kaybetmeyin diye.
Kaybedecekseniz de şu en sonda
kaybedersiniz. O zamana kadar biz
sizinle zaten bütün coğrafyayı bitirmiş
oluruz. Siz fullemeye başlarsınız zaten.
Moralinizi kaybetmemek için muazzam bir
strateji ile bu sene ilerleyeceğiz. O
yüzden bugünkü günümüz ne? Atmosfer ve
etkileri kritik bir konudur. MSÜ'de
çıktı geçen sene, ondan önceki sene
TYT'de çıktı. Ona göre şöyle mavi
tikimizi atalım. Sen de takvimine bunu
işaretle. Şurayı da şurayı da şöyle
işaretledik. Bugünkü çözeceğiniz testler
14 ve 15 olacak. Bu videodan sonra test
çözümünüz de gelecek. Evet, gelelim
şimdi konu kısmımıza. Takvim kısmını
uzun tuttum. Orada çok güzel açıklama
yaptım. Takvim kısmını izle. Buradan
başlama izlemeye. Sayfa kaçı açıyorsun?
Sayfa 29'u açıyorsun. Biz seninle asıl
önemli olan yerden başlayacağız.
Atmosferden. Atmosferi biz kodlama
kısmında ilk yerde görmüştük. Hani böyle
ben paraşütle uçuyordum. Hava küreydi
değil mi? Bu atmosferi oluşturan bazı
gazlar var. Bu gazların bazılarının
oranı değişiyor gençler. Bazılarının
oranı değişmiyor. Mesela bakın burada
şunu bilmeni istiyorum senden. Şöyle
azotun altını çiz. Azotun altını çiz. Bu
%78'le dünyada en fazla bulunan gaz
azot. Sonra oksijen %21 ile oksijen
geliyor. Demek ki en fazla bulunan gaz
hangisiymiş? Azotmuş. Sonra oksijen.
Oranlarını bilmesen bile şunu bil. Yani
sen şimdi normalde düşünürken ya havada
en fazla karbondioksit, oksijen falan
vardır diye düşünüyorsun. Hayır. En
fazla ne var? Azot var. Sonra asal
gazlar var. Bakın bunlar miktarı
değişmiyor. Yani oksijenin miktarı
totalde değişmiyor. Tabii ki dağların
bazı yüksek kesimlerinde, alçak
kesimlerinde belirli miktarda oksijen
fazla ya da az gibi bir şey olabiliyor.
Ama oksijenin miktarı dünyada değişmiyor
gençler. Değişenler hangileri ki asıl
onlar problem yaratıyor bize zaten.
Değişenlerin en önemlisi şu: altını çiz.
Su baharı. Altına şunu yaz. Nem. Bir
sonraki konuda bunu göreceğiz zaten
basınçlardan sonra. Su buharı nem. Su
buharı nem. Hani nemli hava. Nemin az
olduğu hava diyoruz. Su buharı
değişiyor. Mesela suların kenarındayız.
Denizin kenarındayız. Buharlaşma oluyor.
Bak su buharı arttı gibi. Nem arttı.
Deniz kenarında yaşıyorsunuz nem fazla.
Karanın içine gidiyorsunuz Erzurum'a
Kars'a nem az diyoruz. Ha demek ki su
buharının oranı değişiyormuş. Bir de
karbondioksit. Bak oksijeninki
değişmiyor ama karbondioksitinki
değişiyor. Burası önemli. Neden
değişiyor ve bunun etkileri neler? Bunu
küresel iklim değişimine etkisinde
görüyoruz biz çok. Nasıl şimdi? Karbon
içeren fosil yakıtları yakıyoruz biz,
değil mi? Kömür yakıyoruz. Dışarı ne
çıkıyor? Karbondioksit çıkıyor. Ya da
bitkiler fotosentez yapıyor.
Karbondioksiti alıyorlar, tüketiyorlar.
Fosil yakıt yakınca karbonu üretiyoruz.
Bak ne oldu? Dünyada bu karbonun dengesi
demek ki değişebiliyor. Ve karbonu biz
arttırdığımızda yani karbondioksiti
arttırdığımızda havada bu karbondioksit
sıcaklığı tutuyor gençler. Sıcaklığı
tutunca dünyaya gelen güneş ışınları
içeride sıcaklığa dönüşüyor ve o
karbondioksit arttığında o sıcaklığı
içeride hapsediyor. Karbondioksit
sıcaklığı tutuyor. Tutunca da kürenin
ısınmasına neden oluyor. İşte hani biz
küresel ısınma diyoruz ya. Küresel
ısınmanın en önemli etkenlerinden bir
tanesi karbondioksit miktarının artması.
Ha demek ki su buharı ve karbondioksit
değişen gazlarmış. Anlaştık mı? Şimdi
geliyoruz bu konuda bize genelde hep bu
atmosferin katmanlarının özelliklerini
soruyorlar. Atmosferin katmanlarının
özelliklerini öğreneceğiz ama bunu ilk
önce atmosferin katmanlarını
sıralayabilmen lazım. Hemen geçtiğimiz
sınavda MS3'de çıktı atmosferin
katmanları ve biz aynı şu kodlamayla
yaptık onu. Trabzonspor maçı terk etti
kodlamasıyla bunu yaptık. Nasıl
yazacaksın bunu? Şu görseli şuraya
koyuyorum. Bakın bana çok benzetemedim
bunu. Prompt gire gire bir türlü kendime
benzetemedim ama az olsa benziyor.
Trabzonspor maçı terk etti. Aşağıdan
yukarıya doğru yazacaksınız. Nasıl?
Trabzonspor maçı terk etti. Ne demek
hocam bu Trabzonspor maçı terk etti
deeki bu kodlama? Altta bak troposfer
var. Sonra Trabzonspor stratosfer var.
Sonra Trabzonspor maçı mezosfer var.
Terk termosfer Etizosfer var.
Trabzonspor maçı terk et. Anlaştık mı?
Şimdi gelin bu katmanların özelliklerine
bakalım. Şunu şöyle köşeye koyayım
özelliklerini. Resmi de bu tarafa
koyayım. Resimden takip et beni.
Troposfer. Bu gençler neydi? Trabzonspor
maçı terk etti. He en alttaki o zaman.
Şimdi en alttaki ise bunun özelliklerini
ezberlemeyeceksin. En alttaysa bu katman
şöyle bir düşüneceksin. Canlılar burada
yaşar değil mi? Yeryüzüne bak en yakın
katmandır diyor. E ben bunu zaten
kodlamadan çıkarttım. Şimdi su baharının
%99'u buradadır diyor. Bak bunu da
ezberleme. Mantıken düşün. Şimdi
denizler nerede? Yerkürede. O zaman
oradaki buharlaşma ne olacak?
Troposferde olacak. Çünkü bu su buharı
nem ağır bir gaz aynı zamanda çok da
yükseklere çıkamıyor. Ne olacak? O
ağırlığından dolayı aşağıda olacak.
Troposferdeymiş demek ki. Su buharı
buradaysa su buharının olduğu yerde hava
olayları gerçekleşir. O zaman hava
olayları da burada gerçekleşecek.
Anlaştık mı? Burada gençler troposferin
kalınlığı değişiyor. Troposfer
Ekvator'da daha kalın. Bunu az sonra
göstereceğim üç tane nedeni var. İşte
dünyanın dönmesiyile alakalı, oranın
sıcak olmasıyla alakalı. Az sonra
yorumlayacağız onu. Ekvatorda biraz daha
kalın, kutuplarda daha ince. Şimdi bak,
suharının çoğu buradaydı ya. Asıl önemli
olan bilgi şu. Bak, gazların %75'i bu
katmanda. Tabii ki bu %75'i
ezberlemeyeceksin. Sadece şunu aklına
getir. Gazların, bütün gazları düşün.
Bütün gazların çoğu traposferdeymiş.
Neden ezberlemeyeceksin? Bak gençler,
sizin probleminiz şu. Burada madde madde
bilgiler verildi ya. Şimdi oturup
bunları ezberliyorsunuz. Hayır, böyle
değil. Bakın, yabancı bir kavram varsa
biz bunu kodluyoruz. Sonra o koddan onun
Türkçesini çıkartıyoruz ve o
Türkçesinden bilgiyi kendimiz
üretiyoruz. Burada öğrenmede asıl
değerli olan şey şudur. Bilgiyi sen ne
kadar üretebiliyorsun? Dikkat edersen
sana ne dedim? Trabzonspor muhteşem
takım dedik. Kodladık. İlk önce
troposferin nerede olduğunu bir
kodlamayla aklımıza getirdik. Sonra
bilgiyi üreteceksin. Ha burası en alt
katman. O zaman canlıların çoğu burada.
O zaman su baharı az ağır bir gaz. O
zaman suarı da burada. Subarı buradaysa
hava olayları da burada gerçekleşiyor.
Bak gördün mü? Gazların da çoğu burada.
Yine kendin üret bilgiyim. Neden?
Mantığı bir düşün. E gazların bir
ağırlığı yok mu? Gazların bir ağırlığı
yoksa e gazların çoğu o zaman
yerçekiminin etkisiyle nerede olacak? Bu
troposfer katında. Yoğunluk. O zaman
yoğunluk nerede fazla olacak? Troposfer
katında fazla olacak. Bak mantıken
düşün. Aşağı kesimlerde gazların
ağırlığı olduğu için çöküp orada
yoğunluk fazla olacak. Yukarı çıkıldıkça
yoğunluk azalacak. Demek ki mantığı
görüyor musun? Ne yapacaksın? Gençler
bakın burada temel şey bilgiyi
üretebilmek. Ben bilgilerin hiçbir
tanesini ezberlemiyorum. Sen de
ezberleme. Biz sadece aklımıza gelmeyen
yüzlerce kavramı kodluyoruz. İşte
çeşitli bazen şarkı söylüyoruz falan.
Tekniklerle kendimiz o kavramı aklımıza
getirip Türkçesini aklımıza getirip
bilgiyi kendimiz üretiyoruz. Tamam.
bilgiyi üretmeyi öğren. Bak hiçbirini
ezberlemedik. Başka? Sıcaklık 200
metrede 1 derece azalır. Bu katmanda
diğer katmanlarda daha farklı ama
troposferde yukarıya çıkıldıkça 200
metrede bir derece sıcaklık düşüyor.
Bunun nedenini de bundan sonraki derste
sıcaklık dersimiz olacak. Orada daha
ayrıntılı göstereceğim sana. Ama şunu
söyleyeyim. Güneşten bize enerji
geliyor. Yere çarpıyor ve dalga boyu
değişince sıcaklığa dönüşüyor. Ama yere
çarpınca sıcaklığa dönüşüyor. O yüzden
de dünyada en sıcak yeryüzüne en yakın
olan yer. Yukarıya çıkıldıkça da 200
metrede bir derece sıcaklık düşüyor
troposferde. Ama bu bunun mantığını
sıcaklıkta daha ayrıntılı. Göstereceğim
sana. Bunu şimdi böyle bilmen yeterli.
Tamam. Başka? Helikopter gibi hafif
uçaklar. Helikopterler, hafif uçaklar bu
katmanda uçuyorlar. Buraya kadar tamam
mıyız? Troposferin mantığını oturttuk
mu? Güzel. Şimdi gelelim stratosfere.
Şöyle kenara resmi kaymasın ha. Trabzon
troposfer spor spor stratosfer. İkinci
katmana çıktık. Birinci katman
troposferde dikey hava hareketleri
görülüyordu. Yani hava ısınıyordu.
Troposferde hava nasıl? Hava ısınıyor ve
yükseliyor. Dikey. Burada gençler yatay
hava hareketleri görülüyor. Ve burada
jet rüzgarları var. Ben mesela bu ilk
jet rüzgarlarını duyduğumda çok
şaşırmıştım. Japonlar. Dünya Savaşı'nda
galiba tam bilmiyorum bir ya da iki ama
o Dünya Savaşı'nın bir tanesinde o jet
rüzgarlarını yani o jet rüzgarları çok
hızlı rüzgarlar bir eee oluk gibi
düşünün burayı. O jet rüzgarlarını
keşfetmişler. Oralara bomba bırakmışlar.
Oradan Amerika'ya gitmesine neden
olmuşlar o bombaların. Ben şoka
girmiştim bu bilgiyi öğrendiğimde. Jet
uçakları da burada gençler hava olayları
vesaire daha az olduğu için bir stabil
bir hava durumu olduğu için jet
rüzgarları da burayı
kullanabiliyorlarmış. Burada en değerli
kısım ozon tabakasının altını çiz.
Trabzon spor spor yapan ozon diyeceğiz
biz buna. Ozan. Spor yapan Ozan. Ozan.
Eğer ki dinleyen sen Ozansan yorumlara
bunu yaz. Bizi kim koruyor? Bakın resme
bakın. Spor yapan ozan koruyor bizi. E
spor yaparsan korunursun ya. Niye hocam
korumaktan bahsediyorsunuz? Çünkü
gençler ozon tabakası güneşten gelen
zararlı ışınlardan koruyor bizi. O
ultraveli ışınları süzüyor ve bize zarar
vermesini engelliyor. O ışınlar bizi kör
edebilir. Tenimize kanser oluşturabilir.
Bizi kim koruyor? Ozon tabakası. Bu ozon
tabakası da neyin içerisinde?
Stratosferin içerisinde. Tamam. O yüzden
ne diyoruz? Trabzonspor. Aa, spor yapan
Ozan vardı. Spor yapanca bizi korur,
değil mi? Spor yapan Ozan bizi
koruyordu. Spor yapan dememizin nedeni
stratosferin içinde bu Ozan. Buradan
aklına gelecek. Anlaştık mı? Bunlar
bakın direkt sınav sorularını işliyoruz.
Geçen senenin sınav şey bu senenin MS
sınav sorusuydu. Bu spor yapan Ozan
diyen soruyu yapmıştı. Tamam mıyız?
Burada stratosferi de bitirdik mi?
Tamam. Geçiyoruz mezosfere. Bu çok
basit. Bak mezosfer.
Meteorlar. Nasıl mezosfer?
Meteorlar.
Meteorların parçalandığı katman. Gençler
uzaydan bizim dünyamıza illaki meteorlar
gök taşları düşüyor. Ama bu gök taşları
dünyaya ulaşamıyor. Çoğu ulaşamıyor.
Bazıları tek tek ulaşabiliyor. Ama çoğu
ne oluyor? Bu mezosfer katmanında
parçalanıyor. Biz de buna bak. Mezosfer
meteorların gök taşlarının parçalandığı
katman diyoruz. Burada sıcaklık -90
derecelere kadar düşebiliyor. Sıcaklığın
düştüğü bir katman. Stratosferde
sıcaklık yükseliyor. Bu termosfer şeyde
e mezosferde düşüyor. -90'lara falan
düşüyor. Çok çok ilginç. Ben mesela bu
bağlantıyı kuramadım. Siz bir araştırın
bakalım. Chat GPT'ye bir sorun. Kullanın
gençler. Yapay zekayı kullanmayı
öğrenin. Bir sorun bakalım. Bu -90
derece sıcaklığın bu kadar fazla
düşmesiyle meteorların parçalanması
arasında bir bağlantı olabilir mi?
Yorumlarda yazın bakayım. Ben de
öğreneyim sizden. Demek ki mezosferi de
öğrendik. En soğuk katmanmış. Bakın
termosfere geldik. Aslında bunun ismi
üstünde bak termosfer. Trabzonspor
yapıyorduk. Trabzonspor
maçı mezosfer. Terk. Terk. Termosfer.
Adı üstünde term. Terlemek. Sıcak. Bu
katman çok sıcak. 1600 derecelere 2000
derecelere kadar çıkabiliyor. Zaten
ismini oradan alıyor. Bak term. Oradan
gelecek aklına. Termosfer. Terlemek. Aa,
çok sıcak terliyor demek ki. Termostat,
termometre. Bakın bunların hepsi aynı
şey. Sıcaklıkla alakalı. Ha bu katman
demek ki çok sıcak. 2000 dereceye kadar
sıcaklık çıkabiliyor burada.
Artabiliyor. Buranın özelliği bu kadar
sıcak olunca e tabii ki ne olacak? Şöyle
kutup ışıklarını görüyor musunuz? E sen
bu kadar sıcak olursan kutup ışıkları
olur. Değil mi? O sıcaktan tabii ki
bunun e oluşma nedeni sıcaklık değil ama
o dünyanın manyetik alanıyla alakalı bir
durum. Ama buradan aklına
getirebilirsin. Aa, sıcaktan kutup
ışıkları ortaya çıkıyor. O kadar sıcak
ki termosfer katmanında bu kutup
ışıkları. Tamam. Termosfer için bilmemiz
gereken en önemli özellik şöyle.
İyonosfer. İyonosfer katmanı aynı ozon
tabakası gibi ayrı bir katman ve
termosferin içinde. Bazı kaynaklarda bu
iyonosferi ayrı alabilir. Bazılarında
ayrı aynı ayrı almayabilir. Sen bunu
termosferin içinde olacak şekilde soruya
göre cevapla. Tamam. İyonosfer katmanın
özelliği radyo dalgalarının
yansıtılmasını sağlıyor. Bizim
haberleşme sinyallerimizi yansıtıyor. Bu
iyon radyon diyeceksin. Bak kodlaması şu
iyon radyu. İyon radyon. He iyonosfer
radyo dalgalarını yansıtıyor. İyon
radyon şeklinde kodlayacağız. Peki hocam
iyonosferin termosferin içinde olduğunu
nasıl kodlayacağız? Ozon tabakasını
kodlamıştık. Şöyleydi. Ozon spor
yapıyordu. Ha, ozon spor yapıyordu.
Stratosferin içindeydi bu. İyonosfer
termosfer. Şöyle bağlantıyı kur.
Termosfer terlemek. O kadar çok
terliyoruz ki burası çok sıcak. Çok
sıcak. Sonra şey diyoruz. Acaba burada
iyiler mi? Şöyle diyoruz. Merak etmeyin.
İyi onlar. İyonosfer. Bak iyonosfer. İyi
onlar. Merak etmeyin. Çok terlemişler
ama iyi onlar. İyonosfer termosferin
içinde bu şekilde aklına getireceksin.
Diğeri egzosfer en dışta olan
Trabzonspor maçı terk etti en dışta olan
egzoz arabanın egzozu gibi düşüneceksin
bunu. Egzoz da en dışta değil mi? Egzoz.
Egzosfer en dışta. Buraya kadar tamam
mıyız? Tamam. Kodlamayla bunu oturttuk.
Bu çıkar karşınıza. Ona göre. Şimdi
atmosferin kalınlığı ile alakalı
gençler. Atmosferin kalınlığı değişiyor.
Kutuplarda daha inceyken atmosfer
ekvatorda daha kalın oluyor. Nedeni şu:
Ekvator'da hava sıcak. Bak sıcaklık
nasıl etkiliyor? Yorumlamayı öğren
bunları. Şimdi sen şöyle çalışıyorsan
çok yanlış yapıyorsun. Kalınlığı
etkileyen etmenler yaz. Sıcaklık, yer
çekimi, çizgisel hız. Böyle yapıyorsan
çok yanlış yapıyorsun. Bu maddeleri
falan ezberleme. Sadece şunu yapabilmen
lazım. Sana sorulduğunda atmosferin
kalınlığını sıcaklık etkiler mi diye
sorduğunda bunu yorumlayabilmen
gerekiyor. Eğer böyle öğrenirsen iş
tamam. Bunları madde madde ezberleme.
Hiçbir önemi yok. Boş iş onlar. Öyle bir
mantık yok. Ne yapacaksın? Sana soruldu.
Sıcaklık atmosferin kalınlığını nasıl
etkiler? Hemen yorumlamayı öğreten. Ha,
ekvator sıcak. Sıcak hava genleşti. Ha,
kalınlık arttı. Demek ki ekvatorda
kalınlık fazlaymış. Kutuplar, hava
soğuk. O zaman sıcaklık azaldı. Soğuk.
Büzüşlü, gazlar çöktü, kalınlık azaldı.
Anladık mı? Yer çekimi. Şimdi düşün
ortada, dünyanın ortasında çekimimiz var
bizim. Dünya ekvator çekirdekten daha
uzak. E o zaman yer çekimi daha az. E az
olursa gazlar daha rahat gider. O zaman
kalınlık ekvatorda artar. Kutuplar daha
dünya basık olduğu için gençler
çekirdeğe daha yakın. Kutuplar daha
yakın olduğu için daha fazla çekiliyor.
Bak yer çekimi arttı. Gazları çekti.
Kalınlık azaldı. Mantık bu. Çizgisel
hız. Dünyanın dönme hızı var gençler.
Ekvator'da dünya daha hızlı döner. Bu
nasıl bir şey? Bilekliği çıkart
göstereyim diyeceğim de şimdi
çıkartmayla uğraşırsam çıkartamayacağım
iki saat. Dur bakayım. Çizgisel hız
dediğimiz olay şu. Hadi be. Hadi
dur bir dakika yapacağım. Heh çıkarttım.
Şimdi şurası ekvator. Tamam mı? Şu altı
ekvator. Şu üstü kutuplar. Dünya gençler
bakın ekvator çok hızlı dönüyor değil
mi? Çünkü ekvator şişkin. Ekvator şişkin
olunca dünya bak orada hızlı dönüyor.
Bir günde hızlı dönüyor kutuplar.
Kutuplar basık yavaş dönüyor kutuplar.
Bakın işte bak. Ekvator çizgisel hız
Ekvatorda fazla kutuplarda az. O yüzden
Ekvator hızlı döndüğü için bak orada bir
etki var. Savrulma etkisi var. İşte bu
yüzden orada gazlar savrulduğu için daha
kalın oluyor orada. Anlaştık mı?
Kutuplarda daha ince oluyor. Bunun
mantığını anladık mı? Tamam. Kutup
ışıkları da bakın bu manyetik alandan
dolayı oluyor. Termosfer katındaydı
bunlar. Geçelim şimdi atmosferin
etkileri kısmına. Bunları yine
ezberlemiyoruz. Mantıken düşüneceğiz
gençler. Atmosfer aşırı ısınmamızı ve
aşırı soğumamızı engelliyor bizim.
Neden? Çünkü bunu bir mont gibi düşünün.
Bizim dünyanın etrafındaki atmosferi.
Şimdi burada gazlar var ya güneş geldiği
zaman güneş ışınları ilk önce bu gazları
ısıtması lazım. E bunu ısıtmakla
uğraşırken aynı zamanda gazlara çarpıp
dışarıda çıkıyor güneş ışınları. bununla
uğraşırken fazla ısıtamıyor. O yüzden az
ısınıyor dünya. Bazı gezegenler var 100
derece 200 derecelere çıkıyor. Öyle
düşünün. Atmosferi olmayan gezegenler.
Gece tam tersi. Şimdi bu gazlar
sıcaklığı tuttu ya. Gecede bu sıcaklığı
kaybetmeye başlayacaklar uzaya. Gazlar
tuttuğu için sıcaklığı yavaş yavaş
kaybediyorlar. O yüzden dünya yavaş
yavaş ısınıyor, yavaş yavaş soğuyor. Ama
bazı gezegenlerde sabah 200 derece,
akşam -100 derece. Böyle düşünün. Demek
ki bu aşırı ısınıp aşırı soğumayı
engelleyen şey neymiş? Atmosfermiş. Bu
maddeleri ezberlemiyoruz. Yorum yapmayı
öğreniyorsun. Bilgi üretmeyi öğren.
Canların yaşam alanını oluşturur. E
tabii atmosfer olduğu için, oksijen
olduğu için bizim yaşam alanımız. Bunu
basit yorumlarsın. Diğeri güneşten gelen
zararlı ışınları engeller. Bunu kim
engelliyordu? Trabzonspor stratosferde
stratosfer. Niye yazamadım ya? Yazmayı
unuttum. Stratosferdeki ne etkiliyor
bunu? Ozon. Trabzonspor. Spor yapan ozon
engelliyordu. Meteorların parçalandığı
katmandır. Bunu kim engelliyordu?
Mezosfer. Mezosfer Meteorların
parçalandığı katman demiştik. Gölge
erlerinin aydınlık olmasını sağlar.
Buradaki mantık ne gençler? Şimdi bizim
şöyle bir tane dünyada şöyle he dünyada
bir kaya var değil mi? Şimdi kitabımız
var. Bu kitabın bakın şu tarafına güneş
ışınları vuruyor. Benim de tam burada
ışık var. Şimdi bu tarafı da ışık
vuruyor. Burayı iyi aydınlatıyor. Ama
arka tarafına bak. Arka tarafı da
aydınlık. Ya tabii ki buradaki kadar net
aydınlık değil ama bakın orası da
aydınlık. Nasıl oluyor bu? Mesela
atmosfer olmasaydı bu olmayacaktı.
Neden? Çünkü güneş buradan geldi ya
gazlara çarptı, çarptı, çarptı, çarptı.
Bu gazlar sayesinde arka tarafa ulaştı
ve arka tarafı çok fazla aydınlık olmasa
da yine zifiri karanlık olmaktan
kurtardı. Bunun nedeni ne? Atmosfer.
Atmosfer olduğu için gazlara çarparak
tam karanlığın önüne geçiyoruz. Yani
gölge yerlerin aydınlık olmasını
sağlıyoruz. Sürtünmeyi engelliyor. Şimdi
dünyada atmosfer olmasaydı direkt uzayla
sürtünecektik biz. Sürtünmeyi engelledi.
Hava olaylarının oluşmasını sağladı.
Yağmur, kar. Bütün bunlar atmosfer
sayesinde oluyor değil mi?
Ne oldu? Sesim gelmedi sana. Kulaklığım
bozulmadı. Neden? Sesimizi ileten şey
gazlar. Ses. Eğer gazlar olmasaydı ne
olacaktı? Sesimiz sana iletilemeyecekti.
Evet. Atmosferin yoğunluğu aşağı
kesimlerde fazladır. Sana bunu
öğretmiştim. Yani şu şu şekilde yoğunluk
bizim için önemli. Bunu öğren. Şöyle bir
dağımız var. Varsayalım. Bu dağın
gençler alt kısımlarında daha çok gaz
vardır. Yani bu hem yer çekiminin
etkisiyle gazların ağırlığıyla aşağı
çökmesi. Yoğunluk aşağıda fazladır. Üst
kesimlerde gazlar daha azdır. Yani
atmosferin alt tarafında yoğunluk daha
fazladır. Buraya kadar tamam mıyız?
Şimdi geliyoruz hava durumu ve
klimatoloji arasındaki farklara. Hava
durumu bakın şu şöyle. Bir yerdeki kısa
süreli etkili olan hava olayları. Hava
durumunu da işleyen, inceleyen bilim
meteoroloji. Meteoroloji dediğimiz şey
kısa süreli hava olaylarını inceliyor.
Yarın hava yağmurlu olacak. İki gün
sonra kar yağışı olacak. Bak bu
cümlelerin hepsi meteorolojinin inceme
inceleme alanına giriyor. Klimatoloji
ise şöyle klimat iklimse uzun süreli
hava olaylarını inceliyor. Bunu da
inceleyen bilim klimatoloji. Biz bunu
öğrenmiştik. Ne demiştik? İklimatoloji
demiştik. Şimdi bizim için önemli olan
şurası. Bu iklimatoloji ile klimatoloji
ile meteoroloji arasındaki farklar. Bir,
bak, iklim uzun süreli hava olaylarını
inceliyor. Hava durumu yani meteoroloji
kısa süreli hava olaylarını inceliyor.
Aynı benim böyle çizdiğim gibi çiz bunu.
Biz gençler iklimi belirtirken yani bir
yerin iklimini anlatırken size ne
diyoruz? Bak kurak yağışlı değil mi?
Karadeniz yağışlıdır değil mi? Güneydoğu
Anadolu kuraktır. Bak bunlar iklimi
ifade ederken kullandığımız sıcak soğuk
böyle ifadeler. Ama hava durumunu ifade
ederken şurada kare içine alayım. Hava
durumunu güneşli yarın hava bulutlu
olacak yarın yağmurlu olacak 12'ye doğru
rüzgar başlayacak. Bak günlük ifadeler
hava durumunda böyle ifade ediyoruz. Bir
de bir fark daha gençler. İklim şöyle
kırmızıyla işaretleyeyim şunları daha
net olsun. Siz de böyle işaretleme
yapın. Şurada hava durumunda
işaretledim. Bakın iklim geniş alanlarda
etkili olur. Mesela Akdeniz iklimi.
Koskoca bütün Akdeniz'de Ege'yi de hatta
Marmara'nın bir kısmını da içine alıyor.
Bak geniş alanlarda. Ama hava durumu
bugün hava kar yağışlı. Bütün Akdeniz'i
ve Ege'yi içine alamıyor. Daha dar
alanlarda etkili oluyor. Tamam. Gelelim
iklimin etkileri kısmına gençler. İklim
bizim hayatımızın her şeyini etkiler.
Şuraya bakın şimdi tabloya. Bunlar yorum
kısmı. Beşeri sistemleri insanı da
etkiliyor, doğal sistemleri de
etkiliyor. İnsanın karakterine kadar
etki yapabiliyor. Ben mesela
Karadenizliyim. Biraz daha hani çok
çabuk sinirlenen bir insanım. Bir
dakikaya geçiyor ama o ara sinirlenmiş,
kırmış oluyorsun. Kalp kırmış oluyorsun.
Hemen sinirlenebiliyor mesela. Neden?
Çünkü bizim orada o kadar değişken ki
hava gerçekten. Sabah mesela kalkarsınız
saat 10 gibi. Ha bir güneş vardır. Hadi
bir dışarı çıkayım dersiniz. Üstünüz
giyinirsiniz dışarı çıkarsınız. Güneş
yok ortada. Bir anda yağmur başlamış
falan. Hep böyle o dalgaların o şeyi
falan. İlk de bizi gerçekten yani bu
saman alevi gibi hemen parlayabiliyoruz.
Bakın karakteri bile etkiliyor. Kuzeyde
yaşayan insanlar daha soğukkanlı
olabiliyor. İşte sıcak yerlerde yaşayan
insanlar daha sıcak kanlı olabiliyor.
İklim bizim karakterimizi bile
etkiliyor. E turizmimizi zaten
etkiliyor. Denizler var ya da dağlık
kesimlerde kış turizmi yapıyoruz. E
tarım yaparken iklime ihtiyacımız var.
Suya ihtiyacımız var. E bitki örtüsünü
bu tarafta yağış olacak ki bitki örtüsü
olsun. yeryüzünün şekillenmesini
etkiliyor. Yani iklim gençler hemen
hemen her şeyi etkiliyor. Bunu size
yorum olarak belki çıkabilir karşımıza.
Bununla alakalı test sorusu çözeceğiz.
Mantıklı olarak bunların hepsini
yorumlayabilirsin. Nüfusun dağılışını. E
çöl olursa seyrek nüfus oluyor değil mi?
Rasatlar ve meteorolojik gözlem
çeşitleri. Rasat denilen şey gençler
iklimi belirlemek için sürekli gözlem
yapılması. Aletli ya da aletsiz
olabiliyor bu. Buna rasat gözlem. gözlem
demek ismi. Zaten şurada meteorolojik
gözlemlerde sinoptik gözlemle
klomatolojik gözlemler var. Buradaki
fark şu. Sinoptik gözlem dünyada aynı
anda yapılıyor. Bütün herkes, bütün
ülkeler tarafından aynı saatte aynı anda
yapılıyor. Kilomatolojik gözlemlerse
daha çok ülkenin kendi yerel saatine
göre, her ülke kendi saatine göre
yapıyor. Buradaki bu farkı kodlamak için
şöyle yapabiliriz. Sinoptik gözlem.
Sizin sizin optik ortak bak optik ortak
yaptığınız gözlem ha dünyada ortak
yapılan gözlem. Sinop gözlem
klimatolojik gözlem dünyada ortak
yapılmıyormuş. Bu bilgiyi burada bilsek
bizim için yeterli. Bir sonraki derste
iklim elemanlarına sıcaklığa
başlayacağız. Gelin hızlıca kodlama
tekrarına geçelim. Şimdi gelelim
kodlamalarla tekrar edelim. Ne dedik? En
önemli yerlerini tekrar edeceğiz. Şimdi
bütün dersin. Trabzonspor
mu ulan hep eski kodlamaya gidiyor aklım
ya. O Trabzonspor muhteşem takımı
beğenmeyenler için böyle bir kodlamaya
çevirdik bunu. Trabzonspor maçı terk
etti. Eski kodlamaya aklı gidenler kemik
kadrodur. Onlar bayağı eskidir.
Trabzonspor maçı terk etti. Troposfer.
Şöyle biraz kalınlaştırayım. Tropos niye
olmadı ya? Troposfer, stratosfer,
mezosfer, termosfer, egzosfer. Aşağıdan
yukarıya doğru yazdık mı? Yazdık.
Gelelim şimdi şuraya. Bunu yazdık.
Troposfer neydi? En alttaki katmandı.
Hava olaylarının görüldüğü katmandı.
Şöyle hava olayları görülüyordu.
Kalınlığı ekvatorda fazla kutuplara
gidildikçe azalıyordu ve yükseğe
çıkıldıkça sıcaklık 200 metrede bir
derece düşüyordu. Bunu sıcaklık
konusunda ayrıntılı işleyeceğiz. Sonraki
katmanımız stratos verdi. Bunu da şu
şekilde bakın. Görseli gözünüzün önüne
getirin. Jet uçağı koydum. Jet
rüzgarlarının jet uçağının bulunduğu
katmandı burası. Trabzonspordu.
Spor yapan Ozan buradaydı. Ozon
tabakasının bulunduğu katmandı burası.
Stratosfer. Geldik Ozon tabakasına.
Bakın bu şey turuncu. Stratosferin
içindekini yeşil olarak gösterdim size.
Ozon tabakası burada. Bak ozana bak.
Spor yapıyor. Spor yapan ozan bizi
zararlı güneş ışınlarından koruyor. Bak
bu da tamam. Mezosfer, meteorların
parçalandığı katman ve şey demiştik bak
-90 derecelere ulaşabiliyormuş. Soğuktu
burası en soğuk katmandı. Mezosferi de
tamam. Termosfer terlediğimiz sıcak olan
katmandı. Çok sıcaktı burası. Kuzey
ışıkları burada sıcaklıktan dolayı o
ışıklar oluşuyor diyorduk. Bir de burada
terlersen
iyi misiniz diyorduk. İyonosfer
iyi onlar. İyonosfer katmanı bunun
içerisindeydi. İyon radyon bak radyoyu
tutuyor. Radyo dalgalarının yansıtıldığı
katman bunun içerisindeydi. İyonosfer,
radyon. İyon, radyon. En sonda da
egzosfer var gençler. Uydu ve haberleşme
sistemleri için gerekli olanı uydular
genelde bu katmanda oluyor. Tamam.
Uzayla geçiş katmanı burası. Bir
sonrakinde sıcaklık kısmına geçiş
yapacağız. Gelelim rehberlik köşemize.
Geldik. Rehberlik köşemize bugünkü
konumuz ya başarısız olursam korkusu.
İnsanlarda bu korku her zaman vardır ve
bu korkunun olması çok normaldir. Eğer
yoksa sıkıntı vardır. Her insan
başarısız olurum ya başarısız olursam ne
olacak korkusu vardır. Aslında bu korku
biraz olsun sizi tetiklemesi de lazım.
Çünkü böyle bir korku olmazsa zaten
çalışmazsınız da. Bu korku değerli bir
korkudur. Bu korku sayesinde insan biraz
çalışır ama bazılarımız bunu
abartıyoruz. Nasıl? Ya başarısız
olursam, şöyle olursa, böyle olursa
diye. O kadar ütopik bir hale
getiriyoruz ki bunu artık çalışamaz hale
geliyor. Gençler bu başarısızlık
dediğiniz şey hayatta zaten olmak
zorunda. Başarısızlık olmazsa zaten
başarı olmaz. Ya da başarısızlığı
tatmazsanız bir başarıya ulaştığınızda
tadını alamazsınız, zevkini
çıkaramazsınız. Hayattan tat alamaz hale
gelirsiniz. Başarısızlıklar bizi var
ediyor. Ne demek böyle? Bunu herkes der.
Yani başarısızlık değerlidir.
Başarısızlıklar sizi var eder.
Başarısızlık tabii olacak hayatta.
Herkes der size bunu. Ama bak ben size
bunu hayatımdan örneklerle açıklayayım.
Başarısızlık olmak zorunda. Hatta
başarısızlıklar sizi çok daha güzel
başarılara götürür. Ben e 2020 yılında
koronada iken o dönemde tam da koronanın
hemen öncesinde çok ciddi sıkıntılar
yaşadım. Bazı girişimlerde bulundum. Bu
girişimler sonucunda battım. Çok ciddi
borçlar oldu. Tam da üzerine korona
geldi. Orada bir çok ciddi bir yaptığım
girişimlerde başarısız oldum ve battım
sıfırladım. Ne sıfırı? Eksilere düştüm.
Çok ciddi borçlarım oldu. Eksilere
düştüm. Bakın bu normalde o günlerde ben
hayatımı düşündüğümde hayatım bitti
benim için. Çünkü evliydim, boşandım,
bitti. Yani düşünsenize o psikolojiyi
bir düşünün. Eksilerdesiniz, eviniz
dağılmış, yok olmuşsunuz. Bundan daha
kötü bir başarısızlık, bundan daha kötü
hayatın bittiği bir şey olabilir mi? Çok
kötü görünüyor değil mi başta? Ben de o
günler o anı yaşarken, o anları yaşarken
gerçekten bittim ben dedim. Yani hani o
hayatın son şeyine geldim yani. Hani
gerçekten geldim. O hayatın son
çizgisine geldim o anlarda. Ama sonra ne
oldu biliyor musunuz? Oturdum düşündüm
yani ne olacak dedim. Ayağa kalkmayı
bilmem lazım dedim. O gün düştüm ben
gençler. O gün deli gibi başarısız oldum
ve düştüm. Ama sonra ne yaptım biliyor
musunuz? Benim bu kötü gibi görünen bu
olaydan bir şekilde sıyrılıp ayağa
kalkıp yürümem lazım dedim. Ve tam da
orada oturdum. Ben İngilizce öğreneyim
dedim. Niye boşa çıkartacağım? Boşa
geçireceğim bu korona süreciydi. Okullar
tatil olmuştu. Evlere dönmüştü. Niye
boşa geçireyim ki bu süreyi dedim.
Oturayım İngilizce çalışayım dedim. Bir
şeyler yapayım dedim. Bir yerden bir
başlayayım dedim. Oturdum YouTube'dan
İngilizce çalışmaya başladım ve bir ay
İngilizce çalıştım. O süreçte YouTube'u
keşfettim. YouTube'da bir eğitim
platformu olduğunu anladım ve oturdum.
Bu kanal öyle kuruldu işte. Çok kötü
gibi görünüyor değil mi? Yani o gün
dünyanın borcuyla eksilerde hayatım
bitmiş bir şekilde, evliliğim bitmiş bir
şekilde, boşanma süreci başlamış bir
şekilde YouTube'a başladım. Tek başıma
kalmışım hayatta ve YouTube'a başladım.
Orada YouTube'a başladım. Bakın ne oldu?
Bugün geldiğim noktada o gün çok kötü
gibi görünen o olay. Bugün geri dönüp
baktığımda o yaşanması gerekiyormuş. Ya
iyi ki de öyle olmuş diyorum. Bugün
bugün yeni bir evliliğim var. Muazzam
bir hayatım var. yeniden inşa ettiğim
müthiş bir hayatım ve kariyerim var.
Bugün bu noktaya gelmemi sağlayan şey o
gün başarısız olup yere düşmem aslında.
O gün ben başarısız olup yere düşmesem
hayatım milli eğitimde çalışan tek düze
bir öğretmen olarak devam edecek ve
hiçbir zaman belki de bugün geldiğim
noktalara gelemeyecek. Bilemeyiz.
Hayatın size ne zaman hangi kötülüklerle
neyi getireceğini bilemezsiniz. O kötü
gibi gördüğünüz şeyler aslında belki de
sizin hayatınızda kötü güşudur.
Bilemezsin. Ama burada bir şey var.
Burada bakış açısı çok önemli. Hayatta
herkes düşer gençler. O benim ilk
düşüşüm de değildi bu arada. Yani orada
düştüm de YouTube serüveninde bir anda
ayağa kalktım da değil. Bu YouTube'u
yaşarken de bu YouTube'u bu 1 bu5
milyona getirdim. Bu kanalı bunu
büyütürken de en az ü defa düştüm. Daha
5 ay önce bir daha düştüm ben. Sürekli
düşüyoruz gençler. Hayatta her zaman
düşüşler, her zaman başarısızlıklar
olacak. Ama o düşüşlerde her zaman şunu
diyorum ben. Ben her zaman bunu demişim.
Abi herkes düşer. Bu bize güzel bir şey
getirecek. Güzel bir şeyin kapısını
açacak. Ayağa kalkmak lazım. Ayağa
kalkmayı bilmek lazım. Her düştüğümde
ayağa kalk. Her düştüğümde kalk.
YouTube'a başladım. Ayağa kalk.
YouTube'da 7 ay beni kimse izlemedi. 7
ay boyunca hiç izlenmeden video çek.
Günde 10 saat 15 saat canlı yayınlarda
çalıştık öğrencilerimizle. Gidin Rota CK
kanalına bakın. Orada yüzlerce canlı
yayın var. Her biri
saatlik aslında. Yani 12 saatin üstünü
kaydetmiyor YouTube. Çok daha fazla
oturdum izlenmedim. Aylarca tek başıma
çalıştım öğrencilerimle. İzlenmeyen
videolar izlenmemesine rağmen attım. 2
yıl geçti. 2 yıl sonrasında, pardon bir
yıl geçti. Bir yıl sonrasında map'ten
istifa etmem gerekiyordu. 00 lira
kazanırken istifa ettim. .00 lira
kazanıyordum istifa ettiğim gün. 700.000
aboneye gelene kadar ismimi hiç kimse
söylemedi biliyor musunuz? Bakın ne
kadar kötü bir durum düşünün. 700.000
aboneli bir coğrafya kanalı oldum. Kimse
ismimi söylemiyordu ya. O öneriler onlar
bunlar. Kimse ismimi söylemiyordu. Yine
pes etmedim. Devam et. Şükürler olsun
yolumuzu bir şekilde bulduk. Çıktık.
Koşarak devam etmeye başladığımız anda
düştük. Yine daha 5 ay önce düştük.
Oturduk yok oluyorduk gençler. Yok
oluyorduk. Siz bunun farkında
değilsiniz. Bilmiyorsunuz arkadaki o
kısmı biz söylemiyoruz. Yok oluyorduk.
Düştük 5 ay önce kendi yayınımızı kurmak
zorunda kaldık. Ve o yayını kurmak
zorunda kalırken bütün paramızı ortaya
koyduk. Şu an bu kitaplarımızı
çıkaramasaydık içerik yapamayacaktık bu
sene. Bunu kimse bilmiyor. Mesela biz 5
aydır falan gece gündüz çalışıyoruz.
Biraz hani arka planda gizleyerek
yapmaya çalışıyoruz bunu. Çok fazla şey
yapmıyoruz. Bütün paramızı ortaya koyup
yayın olmak zorunda kaldık.
İstemediğimiz bir şeydi. Tamam ya düştük
orada. Tamam kalkacağız bunu da
yapacağız dedik. Kalktık bugün şükürler
olsun yayınımızı kurduk. En çok
satanlarda kitaplarımız yine. Ama o gün
bütün paramızı koyduğumuzda yok
oluyorduk az daha. Paramızla beraber
içerik yapamama riskimiz vardı bu sene
YouTube'a. Şükürler olsun kitaplar
yetişti, kamplarımız yetişti. Yine ayağa
kalk o gün. Ama orada yalnız
kaldığımızda, yayın kurmak zorunda
kaldığımızda, yalnız kaldığımızda hayat
bizim için bitmişti. Bunu
anlayamazsınız. Belki size çok uzak
geliyor ama 8 tane Zedua öğretmeniyiz
biz. 89 tane bunların aileleri. Biz
başka bir yerde çalışmıyoruz. Bizim tek
işimiz YouTube. YouTube'un geliri,
reklam geliri falan bir insanın hayatını
götürmüyor gençler. Ne sanıyorsunuz?
YouTube'dan reklam geliri mi var
sanıyorsun? Bir insanın hayatını
kurtarmıyor. YouTube yapan birinin
hayatını kurtarmasına imkanı yok.
YouTube reklam geriliğe biz öyle eğlence
videosu çekmiyoruz ki milyonlarca
izlensin. O gün 89 öğretmenin
aileleriyle beraber gidiyorduk biz ya. 5
ay önce gidiyorduk yok oluyorduk. Bugün
kamplarımızı yetiştiremeseydik,
kitaplarımızı yapamasaydık yok
oluyorduk. Şükürler olsun o gün biz bunu
dedik. Ya bu kötü görünen şeyin
arkasından çok güzel bir şey gelecek
dedik. Ayağa kalktık deli gibi çalıştık
ve bugün bak yayınımızı da çıkarttık
şükürler olsun. Stüdyolarımızı da
kuruyoruz. Kitaplarımız da çıktı.
Göreceksiniz yeni müfredatta 2 sene
sonra bu Türkiye'nin en büyük beş
yayınından biri haline dönüşeceğiz. Ama
bak o gün o gün bitiyorduk. Bütün
öğretmenler olarak bittiğimiz o yerden
bugün geldiğimiz yere bakın. O kötü
görünen şey yine bize nasıl bir kapı
açtı. Hayatımda her zaman böyle oldu. O
sizin başarısız olarak düşündüğünüz
şeyler aslında size açılmış yeni
kapıların mesajları. Bilemezsiniz
gençler. Hayatınızda hangi
başarısızlığın sizi hangi kapıyı
açacağını bilemezsiniz. Mezuna kaldım.
Mezuna mı kalacağım diye korkuyor musun?
Nereden biliyorsun mezuna kalmak senin
için çok daha güzel bir kapı açacak?
Üniversiteyi kazanamazsam ne olacak?
Nereden biliyorsun? Üniversiteyi
kazanmazsan daha güzel bir hayat seni
bekliyor? Nereden biliyorsun geleceği?
Nereden biliyorsun? Bilemezsin. Burada
yapman gereken tek şey şu: Başarısızlık
korkularının seni ele geçirmesine izin
vermeyeceksin. Herkes başarısız oluyor
zaten ama bazıları başarısız olduğunda,
yere düştüğünde ya buradan güzel bir şey
çıkacak deyip ayağa kalkıp yürümeyi
biliyorlar. Sen de başarısız olacaksın.
Herkesin başarısız olduğu gibi orada
ayağa kalkıp yürümeyi öğren. Başarısız
insan yoktur. Başarısızlıklarından ders
çıkarmayıp ayağa kalkıp yürümeyi
bilmeyen insan vardı. O yüzden korkma.
Hayatın sana ne zaman ne getireceğini
bilemezsin. Sadece kalk, çalışmaya devam
et. Elinden geleni yap. Sonucu kötü bile
olsa sana güzel kapılar açılacaktır her
zaman. Çünkü sen her zaman mücadele eden
birisin.